this episode is brought to you by
literary l-i-t-e-r-a-t-i
i absolutely love what literary is doing
and i've been waiting for someone to
really pull it off
so finally right here in my hometown of
austin but available
nationwide literati let me back up for a
second though if there's one thing i
think we're all craving
after this completely insane captain
insano year
it's an uplifting holiday season we want
the celebrations the community and the
bonding conversations
that will give us some hope and
inspiration going into 2021
that's where literati can really help
literary is a subscription book club
that sends a beautiful book to your door
each month hand-picked by world-renowned
authors and leaders
literati has book clubs curated by
fascinating luminaries
of all different types including the
unbreakable malala yousafzai
basketball icon stephen curry
entrepreneurial legend richard branson
and famed author and new york staff
writer
susan orlean there are many many
different folks
to choose from and the focusing function
here
the filtering function is what's
important
because with more than a million new
books released every year finding the
right needle in the haystack the best
signal amidst the noise
can be really hard it can be super
daunting and literati
takes care of it for you every month you
get one paperback or hardcover book
that's specific to your luminaries club
like malala's club fearless or stephen
curry's club underrated
these are life-changing books personally
picked by awe-inspiring people
there's a personal forward from your
luminary in each month's book
and you're also able to use the literati
app to discuss what you read with people
who are reading the same book
as well as the luminaries slash curators
themselves so they do engage
the literary app gives you exclusive
access to discussions led by malala
stephen curry richard branson susan
orlean and others
you won't get insight or access like
this anywhere else and the way they put
it together is really beautiful
i have seen a couple of different
packages that have been sent to me
and they're just gorgeous they're really
well done and it makes
the act of reading easy and it makes it
extremely pleasant so get the books
that the world's most fascinating minds
are reading every month and you can
cancel any time
you can give subscriptions which are
available for 3
6 or 12 months of books it's a great way
to keep the holiday magic going through
2021 whether you're gifting a friend a
family member or yourself
and it's easy go to literati.com tim
to find your perfect book club and sign
up today that's l-i-t-e-r-a-t-i-dot-com
tim no one else has book clubs quite
like these go to literati.com
tim to get one book every month curated
by today's leading authors and
visionaries so make your holidays
unforgettable this year and make someone
else's holidays unforgettable
might as well go to literary.com tim one
more time this literati.com
tim
this episode is brought to you by
headspace life can be stressful
even under normal circumstances 2020 has
challenged
even the most resilient people i know
it's highlighted
just how much we all need stress relief
that goes beyond quick
fixes or really the hope for just a
one-and-done band-aid
quick is fine but we need stuff that is
durable and that's where headspace
comes in headspace is your daily dose of
mindfulness in the form of guided
meditations
in an easy to use app now you might ask
yourself
very reasonably there are 2000 plus apps
for meditation
why would i use headspace headspace is
one of the only meditation apps
advancing the field of mindfulness and
meditation through clinically validated
research
headspace is backed by 25 published
studies on its benefits
600 000 5 star reviews and more than 60
million
downloads so if people keep telling you
to try meditation and you're like when
would i do that
when would i possibly have time you
should check out headspace if you have
10 minutes
headspace can change your life headspace
offers a really
light lift and a lot of features
to keep you going which is part of the
reason that i've used headspace
for years now so whatever the situation
headspace can really help you feel
better overwhelmed headspace has a three
minute sos meditation for you need some
help falling asleep
headspace has wind down sessions their
members swear by and for parents
headspace even has morning meditations
you can do with your kids
headspace's approach to mindfulness can
reduce stress improve sleep
boost focus and increase your overall
sense
of well-being and it really starts with
very very
simple practices and if you look at
my case for instance i just went through
one of the basics
today with the co-founder
andy i think it's puddicum could be
puddi comb i'm not sure but former monk
turned into co-founder of headspace has
the most soothing hypnotic voice
imaginable
and i did a three minute meditation
something like that it's
easy it's fundamental and it always puts
me in a better
space so i'm going through the basics
even though i've meditated for years i'm
going through the basics once again
and i would suggest to anyone that they
consider starting there
headspace makes it easy for you to build
a life-changing meditation practice with
mindfulness that works for you on your
schedule
anytime anywhere we all want to feel
happier
we all want more peace and headspace is
meditation made
simple go to headspace.com tim
that's headspace.com tim for a free
one-month trial
with access to headspace's full library
of meditations for every
conceivable possible situation you can
break glass in case of emergency in
almost any situation and find something
on headspace this is the best
deal offered right now for headspace so
check it out go to headspace.com
slash tim today
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal questions
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of
the tim ferriss show my guest today is
none other than daniel eck
who is daniel daniel is the founder
chief executive officer and chairman of
the board of directors of spotify
most of you have heard of it the world's
most popular audio streaming
subscription service
with roughly 320 million users including
144 million or so subscribers
across 92 markets daniel welcome to the
show
thank you so much for having me i
thought we would start
with a word i have never known how to
pronounce
and it is your twitter handle
at e-l-d-s-j-a-l
could you please explain what this is
yeah sure so the swedish pronunciation
is el dejel
it's a very special swedish word i
actually don't think that the word
exists
in english or any other language but
it's basically
the direct translation is a fiery soul
and it means someone who's intensely
passionate about something
and is kind of there in the good and the
bad times and perseveres
that's basically kind of um what the
name implies so you usually find it in
um you know um the green peace movement
20 years ago or you find it uh when
someone's passionately fighting the
local government
somewhere those are usually those types
of people
and you know it just always resonated
with me so is that
one of your favorite words or the
connotations of it was it a nickname
given to you
how did it end up your twitter handle
was it's a reminder to yourself
yeah i think it was honestly it was
really a
more of a reminder to myself and an ode
to
a younger me because i was often called
that
because you know whatever the issues
were that i was passionate about
um people saw that passion uh a mile
away and they always saw
me advocating for this long before i
realized i was going to be an
entrepreneur and long before i realized
you know i would start spotify so it
kind of just
felt like a very fitting name for who i
am
and you know it's it's just kind of been
a part of
my identity and a part of the things
that i tend to get involved with they
all kind of share that characteristic
you mentioned i'm not even going to try
to pronounce it and i'm so glad i didn't
try
yeah how do you say it one more time
well i'm not going to get it's actually
pretty good thanks
it's actually pretty good and it would
usually have an umlaut over the a
is that right the two dots yes yes
that's correct
so it's a very very swedish word you
indicated that it's a word that doesn't
really have
a corollary in english and there are
lots of words
in different languages like saudaji and
brazilian portuguese or i should say in
portuguese doesn't really exist in
english
are there any other words
in swedish that you
care for that come to mind that just
don't have a good equivalent in english
well there's actually a number of them
another one of my favorites
is a word called lagom it's a word
we use internally at spotify quite a lot
actually
and lagom in sweden is i think the best
translation i could give is it's just
about right it's not too much and it's
not too little
and it's kind of i think encapsulates
the swedish spirit
more maybe than anything else like in in
sweden it's very much a culture of you
shouldn't stand out
um you're part of a collective being
and the best thing you can be in the
swedish society is being lagom
just about right like not too much and
not too little that's
that's kind of what every swede aspires
to be
which which feels crazy if you're an
american because that's about
individuality and expressing yourself
and
don't be afraid to kind of like take
space but it's completely opposite in
the swedish society
in the context of spotify is logging
if i'm butchering that but trying my
best
is that for a minimal viable product
is it for launching in what context does
that word
get used in the company yeah i think
it's
more around our culture so you know we
have in spotify
these two kind of distinct subcultures
as part of it it's the american part
which is a very very large part of
spotify today and very inspiring to me
too
i i'm clearly swedish and people can
hear it on my accent but
i've spent most of my time probably for
the last 20 years
involved in things related to america i
know more than most foreigners about
u.s politics sports everything that's
going on there too
and so the spotify culture is kind of a
hybrid between the two
but if you're an american and you
encounter the swedish culture
it's going to feel incredibly foreign
and so it's one of those things that we
use
internally to explain why there's
some euphemisms or things that we do in
the culture
then it tends to be the swedish side or
the logan side
of the company and for me personally
like this has kind of always been the
internal conflict because
i've never wanted to confine myself to
this logo
but i have you know certain traits of it
for sure
especially by us standards and you asked
me about sort of my
nickname on twitter too and my favorite
quote probably above all is the george
bernard
shaw quote you know the reasonable man
and the unreasonable man
i don't know if you've ever heard that
fits himself to the world versus
fitting the world to himself therefore
all progress depends on the unreasonable
man
am i getting that correct yeah yeah and
and and now think about the sort of
swedish conformist society where
everyone's supposed to be the same and
and then you have me
coming into this society basically
wanting to be the unreasonable man
and you can see the clash while there's
still
certain aspects of it that i i like the
fact that
it's it's about a collective teamwork
it's not about the individual
it's about meritocracy in the sense that
you know everyone can have a voice
all of those things are very important
to me and
very i think swedish values as well so
spotify is really kind of its roots is
in the mix between
swedish and american and then it's kind
of evolved to being distinctly spotify
it sounds like your personal story too
and i'd be super curious to hear
if you came out of the womb as a
fire soul and being sort of half or
maybe 70 percent
rugged individualist or if
you were somehow encouraged to
develop in that way because even in the
united states there will be people
listening
who are perhaps in a conservative family
and i don't mean politically speaking
but a family where they're not
encouraged to stand out where they're
encouraged to follow the rules
to go to high school college
get a job get married to have two kids
and follow a script of some type
even though i think it's less pressure
perhaps or expectation than you would
find
in some parts of scandinavia or a place
like japan
did this just come to you innately or
was it cultivated
in some way i've thought about it a lot
and
i think the best i could say is i don't
think that there's anything distinct in
the culture you know
some have the immigrant background where
they had to fight for everything to
begin with and therefore
that was kind of a part of their story
and who they were
i grew up in very much a working class
family
my mom worked in a daycare center my
stepdad was a car mechanic
no one i knew was an entrepreneur around
me so that certainly wasn't
something to aspire to but what i do
think my parents gave me
that it was incredibly important um and
i think it's
certainly been a trait that i've been
able to find
with a lot of the entrepreneurs that are
kind of in my generation too
is a lot of psychological safety
so what my parents did do very often was
allow me to explore things allow me to
sit
in and be part of grown-up conversations
and not
relegated just to the kids table and
allow me to indulge
curiosity trying to answer the questions
even admitting that they may not know
the answer
trying to help me find the sources that
can help me find information
that then satisfied my curiosity and i
think
a lot of that then created that kind of
drive
from just that sort of safety i always
felt
and you know it's actually i think super
interesting when you think about this
sort of european
society model versus the american one
and i'm not taking sides but i think you
know a lot
about the american model is clearly the
necessity that creates the hunger
sort of the fact that you have to strive
and should strive for betterment
and if you don't try to work hard and
so on you will not do well in society
and the european one is more like no
there's a base level of security
everyone should have food on their table
everyone should have a house to live in
everyone should be able to afford
clothes and things like that it may not
be the nicest clothes but
that kind of level of security exists
there and education is free and
healthcare is free so
none of those things are things you have
to work hard for
and you know i've thought long and hard
about that and
obviously i think there's situations in
where
one leads to a different outcome that
may be beneficial in both models
but in particular one of the big things
i think is
i think the reason why sweden for
instance have so many
talented songwriters and musicians that
are doing so well
comes exactly from that music education
in sweden
is free and if you want to try to make a
living as a musician
you know that the base is taken care of
meaning
you can be on welfare for a period of
time and that's
an okay situation for a period of time
while you go for your dreams
and because music education is free
everyone can afford to do that and can
follow their
curiosity where it takes you so there's
just inherently different
structures and i think for various
personality types leads to different
outcomes but for me
i'm not sure i would have done so well
if i was forced by society to
kind of early on prove my worth i've
been more of a tinkerer a wanderer and
i've always
because i felt the safety i felt that i
could think bigger and try new things
because honestly the consequences of
failing
were minimal yeah that is i think a
really
important both philosophical and
structural difference that you're
pointing out
in certainly a lot of europe compared to
the us
and i could see you know arguments for
both
fostering entrepreneurship certainly the
arts i think more so
in in europe for the reasons that you
mentioned you have kids
and how are you thinking about
raising your kids if you're open to
discussing it
with respect to providing enough safety
net that they feel
they can experiment and tinker but not
so much safety net that they feel
uh or not so much cushion perhaps that
they feel they can
just stare at the wall right and watch
paint dry yeah
you know i don't know i that i've
figured it out or that i have a sort of
magic recipe i'm still
very much early in that evolution my
kids are five and seven
but what i do try to pass on
is i i believe in fostering creativity
and safety that's the kind of two
principles that is
incredibly important in my household but
in order to do that
i actually believe in constraints and
this is an important part because
i feel like you know one of the greatest
things in my day job today is i get to
meet some of the most creative people
in the world in their various fields
including of course music and arts
but the interesting thing for me when
you think about creativity is most
people associate it with
unstructured thinking and unfeathered
just like they do whatever they feel
like doing
but some of the most creative people
that i know are actually incredibly
almost scripted in their creativity and
their approach
in their process and how they approach
their creativity
and so i think in that sort of polarity
between
the structured and the unstructured
there's so much
value and so what i try to do is i try
to
provide those kind of clear boundaries
if you will
with my kids when it comes to things
like
you know how much time they can sit in
front of a tv or an ipad
you know how you behave towards other
people irregardless of where they come
from
it's a lot of sort of values principles
even if you're five
let's make your own bed kind of thing so
that kind of structure around you
but then at the same time almost
montessori style kind of
work with them on evolving their
passions what are they interested in
following along
their journey and kind of nudge them in
various ways
just to discover their own creativity
discover their own
kind of interests and passion and i have
no idea where it
ultimately will lead to but my hope is
that
it creates a way for them where they
feel the
psychological safety to pursue their own
path
in life independently of mine because i
think that's the most important part is
they are their own individuals i have no
idea ultimately
where they want to take life and what
ultimate passions that they have
but i feel very strongly that it
shouldn't be
my vision of what their lives should be
that should be the dictating factor
there and that's at least something i've
observed
feeling that from friends and growing up
that that's been important to me to not
do to my
kids thank you
yeah it's i can only imagine since i
don't have kids myself but
like watching the emergent development
of these personalities
and observing all the different
influences hopefully some of which are
most of which are positive
and you know shape them into their own
individual selves
and i'd love to ask you about i don't
know if
influences would be the right word but
books specifically might
because my my listeners often enjoy
hearing about
books since they might not have access
to some of the people who have
influenced you but they may
have equal access to books you were kind
enough to
be one of the featured profiles in my
last book travel mentors
and there's a question about the books
you've given most
as a gift and why or what books have
greatly influenced your life and i'd
like to talk about two of them
the first one is a book i have not
personally read and it's black box
thinking
subtitled the surprising truth about
success by and i may get this last name
wrong but matthew syed
s-y-e-d and
i would love for you to just describe
how you came across this book why you
find it interesting
oh wow it's funny i probably i should
say i read
probably north of 60 or 70 books a year
so i i often times yeah i often
don't remember exactly how i come in
contact with
things it's almost like a serendipitous
process where
i buy a book because someone usually
recommended it
and me hearing maybe a minute or two
about it and then
i probably shouldn't admit this but then
it often lies on my coffee table
for a while and it's when i have
curiosity poor boredom whichever one
hits the first
um that i tend to kind of delve into
that book
and sometimes i finish it straight away
because it kind of fits my mental state
and sometimes
it is more of a sort of journey where
i i may start it uh may not finish it
and then come back even
the next day or next week or next month
and it's a process
but i've always been specifically to
this book i've always been
fascinated with decision making and
thinking um and how you what kind of
biases and cognitive tricks that
ends up happening in your mind as you
approach different situations i'm
fascinated by the fact that you and i
may even
be experiencing this conversation
entirely differently
with entirely different perspectives and
entirely different agendas
so what i felt was that matthew kind of
articulated some pretty useful
frameworks for
how to approach thinking how to approach
situations what are good feedback loops
for thinking what are good
mental models if you will to approach
that approach decision making and and
therefore it's been
uh one of the more recommended books
from me
you mentioned i can't remember the exact
word frameworks or tool kits i know
you're also a fan of
of charlie munger and poor charlie's
almanac we don't have to spend too much
time on that because i think a lot of
people will recognize that book
but it seems to me based on the next
book i'm going to mention which is the
alchemist
that toolkits alone are not
sufficient necessary but not sufficient
if you want to achieve some degree of
success you also have to
implement and persevere right and right
this is where the driving spirit comes
in
and i'll just read this paragraph really
quickly because i think it's i think it
provides some context so the alchemist
by apollo cuello
and this this is your words feel free to
fact check if need be but i spent an
inspiring evening with paulo in
switzerland around the time we were
launching spotify in brazil it was such
it was fascinating to talk to him about
how this book came to be such a hit he
never backed down and he allowed people
to read it for free in order to then
boost sales
much like how spotify's freemium model
was perceived in the early days
as you allude to here because i've had
apollo on
the podcast a lot of people only
think of the alchemist as this gigantic
mega international phenomenon
selling 50 million or 75 million 100
million who knows what the copy
the number of copies is now but it was
it was rejected
repeatedly in the beginning yeah yeah
and could could you speak to and i'll
segue from this to something else in a
minute but
could you speak to what impact that had
on you whether it's the book or just the
conversation about
the book with paulo well i think i'm so
inspired by
people who are thinking on different
wavelengths
than yourself and for me paolo has
certainly been one of those individuals
i tend to draw myself to where i feel
comfortable which is
around logic reason the
engineering mindset but there's a big
part of myself
and where i come from too you know i
come from a music family where
music and emotions and feelings are
inherently
incredibly important too and paulo for
me
uh represents not the free spirit
but more spirituality but in a way where
he can reason about it
he can talk about it and the big
takeaways i've had is
thinking about sort of for me two
very profound concepts which are kind of
probably
self-explanatory to most people but it's
it's really this notion of
time and this notion of energy and
and when i think about those two things
you know time
is the one commodity we can never get
more of and
energy is your state of being in the
present
time and for me i used to be just
honestly i was not in a great shape
i weighed probably 40 or 50 pounds more
than what i weighed now
i didn't work out i was working you know
100 hour work weeks
i looked at other people that weren't
working as hard as i was and kind of
was discouraged by that and just thought
they could never make it and and they
don't understand what it what's needed
to be and reading the book talking to
paulo
i think started a process within me it
didn't culminate at that point but it
accommodated years later but it started
a process
about sort of thinking about the
spirituality thinking about the energy
side of things and where i am today
which is vastly different
i still constantly work on myself but
it's
i think a lot more about balancing
energy
in my everyday life and overall and you
know it's
you can't really balance it but it's
about finding enough
things to do that gives you positive
energy and we all have to do things that
take energy as well but even even during
a
day make sure that if you have a few
things that you know will take energy
from you
balance it up by adding a few things
that will add energy to your life
and try to find those things that
constantly do that
those are things which are kind of
unintuitive
takeaways from the book i would say but
the book for me
represents more of a kind of inner
process that it started rather than the
very specific part and we're all on a
journey
i think that's the kind of big takeaway
from the book
and finding out what that journey is and
and thinking about it bigger than just
what our financial goals are or what our
career goals are or the the next week or
next month
and think about it in a broader
perspective with energy with life
for me has been sort of a big catalyst
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront did you know
if you missed 10 of the best performing
days after the 2008 crisis you would
have missed out on fifty percent
five zero percent of your returns don't
miss out on the best days in the market
stay invested in a long-term automated
investment portfolio wealthfront
pioneered the automated investing
movement sometimes referred to as robo
advising
and they currently oversee 20 billion
dollars of assets for their clients
wealthfront can help you diversify your
portfolio minimize fees and lower your
taxes
takes about three minutes to sign up and
then wealthfront will build you a
globally diversified portfolio of etfs
based on your risk appetite and manage
it for you at an incredibly low cost
wealthfront software constantly monitors
your portfolio day in and day out so you
don't have to
they look for opportunities to rebalance
and tax loss harvest to lower the amount
of taxes you pay
on your investment gains their newest
service is called autopilot
and it can monitor any checking account
for excess cash to move into
savings or an investment account they've
really thought of a ton they've checked
a lot of boxes
smart investing should not feel like a
roller coaster ride let the
professionals do the work for you
go to wealthfront.com tim and open a
wealthfront investment account today
and you'll get your first five thousand
dollars managed for free for life that's
wealthfront.comtim
wealthfront will automate your
investments for the long term and you
can get started today
at wealthfront.com time
let's talk more about things that give
positive energy and i suppose part of
that would be
rebuilding or refining the machine in
which we all live right the physical
body and you mentioned that you used to
weigh something like 40 pounds
more than you do today a lot of people
struggle
to lose weight what finally ended up
working for you or what made the
difference in terms of getting you at
least started
in successfully losing weight it
honestly it was easy and it was hard
in that it inherently i i was trying to
do things
in the past and and actually like many
people i was successful
for a period of time and then i i kind
of went back to
my old ways and then i started
eating poorly again not sleeping well
enough stressing more
etc and then quickly weight gain
followed
and where it kind of clicked and changed
is i realized
that i needed to actually change my life
and change my habits and the only way to
do that would to do
it sustainably with things that i
actually enjoyed doing
and what i learned in in it was that
um you know i didn't think much about
training i didn't think it was
that interesting i didn't think that you
know i thought i
needed to be on a treadmill for like an
hour a day
sweating like a pig and hating every
moment of it and
that's training i didn't think it was
for me and
and what i realized instead was uh
finding those
small enjoyments like when you start the
process like
i didn't then go to the gym every single
day i started going maybe
two days a week and made it a pattern
and i
really made an effort to try to make
every single time
enjoyable in whatever way so the things
i really didn't enjoy i
i tried to skip but it didn't lean away
from the sort of pain of training but
more kind of
trying to do the things that i actually
thought was fun and more interesting
and then the two days turned to three
and then the three turned to four
and then as i was doing that i started
seeing some results and
and and but i always thought about can i
keep this can i keep this going it
wasn't going to be a one-time kind of
shift uh and then you know what happens
is once you start doing that and you
start enjoying it then you start
realizing well i'm not actually
accomplishing my goals unless i also
shift my diet
all right well what are the things there
that i truly enjoy
and i learned there was a number of
things in my
diet that i was doing that i actually
didn't need and didn't even care all
that much
by removing and it could be all the
smallest things like i used to have
milk in my coffee but in all honesty
i don't really think it makes a huge
difference to have milk or not
but if you have um three or four cups a
day
it adds up and i used to take the
elevator not the stairs but i
actually kind of enjoyed taking the
stairs so it was just a
creature of habit now i mostly take the
stairs
and so it's these small micro things
that then eventually kind of added up
but more importantly in the end despite
the process
what i've realized is that it it made
myself
more sustainable it made made it so that
i had more energy
and the energy i could actually make
myself
more productive in my everyday life
whether that was work or whether that
was relationships to friends
or even as a father to my children all
of it
had a profound impact thank you for
sharing all that this
highlights so many i think extremely
important takeaways
for a lot of folks who struggle with
weight loss number one is that
the small things seem small in isolation
but when you add them together
like the milk and the coffee they can
actually have a really significant
impact and i know people who have lost
five to ten pounds in a given month just
by removing
the milk from their coffee it sounds
absurd but i've seen it over and over
again because
the the milk is so insulinogenic it it
really has
quite a disproportionate impact and the
importance also
of adherence right in in so much as
the best program doesn't matter whether
it's losing weight
learning how to code or anything else if
you can't stick with it long enough for
it to achieve the desired effect
and to sustain it so those little those
little tweaks
really cumulatively can have a huge
impact
i'd like to come back to the 100 hours a
week
when you're working 100 hours a week you
you continue to work
very hard and that is i think certainly
a defining characteristic but even more
so for me
it seems like one of your defining
characteristics is the ability to
focus and prioritize focusing and you
mentioned
earlier that a lot of the most creative
people in the world schedule their
creativity i mean this is true
across the board right whether it's
jerry seinfeld or
certain musicians i've spoken with the
most consistently
creative people have rules and
structures
and constraints so it seems like you've
done something very much the same
to box out time to focus
and i just want to perhaps
give an example of of what your schedule
might look like and i want you to
correct this if it's
changed but this is from the observer
effect and
the question was about the schedule in
the morning and here's how it goes i'll
just read a few lines
quote so this will sound incredibly lazy
compared to some leaders i wake up at
around 6 30 in the morning and spend
some time with my kids and wife
at 7 30 i go work out at 8 30 i go for a
walk even in winter i found this is
often where i do my best thinking at 9
30 i read for 30 minutes to an hour
sometimes i read the news but you'll
also find an ever-rotating stack of
books in my office
next to my bed on tables around the
house books on history leadership
biographies it's pretty eclectic mix
much like my taste in music finally my
quote unquote work day
really starts at 10 30. does your
schedule still
look pretty similar to this or is it
changed
uh no it's pretty similar actually today
i started at 11 a.m was my first
kind of thing uh so i ended up getting
30 minutes longer than
i anticipated but but uh yeah i mean
this is pretty much
my everyday life and i think paul graham
of y combinator fame
um said a few years ago he penned this
paper that was
kind of an aha moment for me about a
meeting
schedule or maker schedule yeah how
different they are
and it was like something kind of
resonated deeply with me and
i think a lot of people think they have
to be
in the meeting schedule all the time and
that that is what's required to be an
effective leader
where in reality i think you can kind of
be an effective leader
no matter what your style is but it has
to be true to you
so that you can unlock your own sort of
superpowers
and in general i would say most people
don't stop
enough and think hard enough about their
priorities and
focusing on the problems that is the
most worthwhile for them to try to
solve and they more operate on a kind of
first come first served
basis when it comes to their time so it
pretty much
is the way my current schedule works too
and i
often don't take more than three or
maybe four things that i do
on each and every day and i try
to be very very sort of tough
on saying no which isn't always the most
fun thing to do i will say
but it also means as a factor that i
tend to
get more stuff done of the things that
truly matter
in a given day and more time to think
about other things
as well than perhaps a normal kind of
ceo
in a normal kind of 9 to 5 or nine two
seven gig whatever they end up doing and
i wanna
give an example of one question
that might i don't say surprise people
but be noticeably
lacking from the the mindscape of a lot
of people from
from day to day and this is this is the
question
of what your role is at a given meeting
what is my role and i've read about your
contemplation of this of this question
but when you go into a meeting
what different roles might you have and
why is it important
to be clear beforehand on what your role
is if we actually take a step back and
we think about work
for a moment and we think about work for
knowledge workers because it's clearly
different the reality is a lot of
knowledge workers that work
in companies most of the work that
they're
doing is done in meetings
some of us do some actual other work too
but a lot of it
ends up being in meetings and it's
surprising to me that we spend as little
time as we do
on actually thinking about the meetings
we're having
if they're productive if they're
worthwhile and if they're delivering
on what the ambition was and
i can only say that when you survey
people
they tend to when you ask if the meeting
was effective or not
most people actually say that meetings
are wasteful and yet we see more and
more and more of it
and so i like to think that a
huge point of optimization can be done
by
designing better meetings for people and
you know early on it started with my own
sort of process
at spotify not just thinking about how
much time we were wasting but
frankly in a meeting what i found myself
many times in
was maybe meeting a person in the
company
that had done a tremendous job putting
together a presentation of some kind
and if i put myself in that person's
shoe this is a person that may
get a meeting with me maybe once maybe
twice during their entire career at
spotify
and for that person it could be the
chance to get noticed for a future
promotion
it could be the chance to have something
that
fundamentally changes their career and
so it often times
what ended up happening was the person
came in and they ran through a
powerpoint that someone had sent me the
night before i had already read it and
they
invertebate them read the entire thing
and then in the end there would be a
short period of time
usually less than 10 of the meeting was
spent on that
of us discussing what the next steps
would be
again i understand why this happens
because again the person that's
presenting this have all the incentives
to kind of show off the good work that
they're doing
and want to seem very competent and
realize that a lot is on the line etc
and instead what i find is that quite
often
we haven't been intentful about why the
meeting exists to begin with
and in this case if it's recognition we
want to give i'm sure
there could have been a better way we
could have done that and we should have
been clear that we were having a review
meeting
about the progress of a certain area and
it should have been clear
too that this person is an amazing
individual and that we should all
try to give constructive criticism but
then in the end also give
feedback positive feedback as well
because we want to make sure this
person feels valued but oftentimes all
of that context
doesn't exist and so my role in that
meeting could sometimes be just
being that person who says that kind
thing but i will
realize more often than not that i had
to prep
people on how to do meetings and
set it up like i do read the meeting
material beforehand
i prefer spending only five minutes in
the beginning
rereading the material or the person
reading it a summary
out of it and states the reason for the
meeting
up front and then we can spend more time
talking about
were these the right questions should we
have considered something else
and what are the appropriate next steps
but you can be an approver you can be
consulted you can be informed
in a meeting and i think many people
always think that if you're the ceo your
job is always to be the approver in the
meeting but i find
if you have a great team that's not at
all the role you should have
you should be sometimes the person who's
only consulted about what they're doing
as an fyi sometimes you can be
the person who just isn't the decider
because there's someone more competent
making that decision but you could be a
person
who is the sounding board where you can
bounce ideas off if we're thinking
aggressive enough if you're thinking
roughly in this dimension should we
invest a lot should we invest a little
in in that decision and all those things
is highly contextual
and your role in those meetings could be
very different depending on
all those variables and being clear and
upfront about
that meetings can have different forms i
think has
profoundly changed how i look at
meetings
and i think a lot of people like spotify
too and i want to mention
the url of paul graham's essay
that you gave note to just a bit earlier
for people who are interested because
this also had
quite an impact on me paulgram has a lot
of fantastic essays and they're short
for people who
are worried that this is going to be 50
pages it's probably a two-page read
but paulgram.com forward slash makers
schedule
dot html and you can just search maker's
schedule
and uh has has profound implications for
anyone who seeks to create in any way
whether it's in a company or
as a creative professional like an
artist for instance i think it's just an
outstanding essay
and i'd like to hop next to
an annual cadence so i've read about you
sitting down
with everyone on your leadership team
once per year
and doing a mental closing of the year
what went well one went poorly
and specifically in addition to that
is this what you want to do for the next
two years and
i'll this i'll just quote this is from
fast company
and if they decide not to you know it's
not personal it's not because of poor
performance at this level it's never
about that it's about
future performance i find this very
interesting but i'd love for you to
flesh out some of the details do you
still do a mental closing of the year
using some type of format like this yeah
we do and and i'm actually right about
i'm writing my reviews at the moment
for all of my employees and i'm gonna
start
not all my employees all my direct
reports and i'll start talking to them
about it
in the next week or two uh so it's still
very much
sort of top of mind for what we do and
maybe i can just kind of
say what the genesis is of that and
please this is kind of inspired by
reed hoffman's tour of duties concept i
was thinking about
my own journey at spotify and you know a
lot of times
the easy way to say it is i've had the
same job for 14 years
but obviously my job looks nothing like
it
from the beginning because you know in a
startup it's very different than running
a public company
with a global presence etc etc and so
when i summarize that and i think about
it and part of the reason why
i'm still excited about the job i'm
doing every day and not just the company
is because i'm probably on my eighth job
at spotify and what i came to realize is
that part of the reason why
the tenure of people at companies
end up being relatively short um
certainly in silicon valley and a lot of
tech companies is that
this job journey when you deal with
startups is
it doesn't always confirm to better
titles
sometimes you retain the same title but
in reality
your job looks very different and
i don't think we're clear enough
especially in startup environments which
are incredibly fast growing if you think
about a company that's growing 100
per year and you fast forward three or
four years down the future
it is impossibly the same company and it
it is impossibly so that your job could
be exactly the same as it was
a few years earlier and most people
aren't clear about that
um so they just assume that because the
person used to do the job
that they'd be perfectly happy continue
to do in that job
and circumstances obviously change no
matter if you
make changes or just by virtue of growth
that i started calling it out explicitly
by just kind of mental marking and
saying
you know we should try as a leadership
team to
see around corners and try to predict
what does the future
company look like you know when when
spotify was a thousand person company
i said to the team you know in the next
journey will be five to ten thousand
people and everyone could buy into that
but then we started
aligning on what are things uh going to
have to look like
for that then uh if if we are a five
thousand person
company what are the sort of things that
will have to change what are some of the
things that will change even for your
role and
you realize as an example if you're a
leader of
ten people versus a thousand people your
job is so different
because you know you're a leader of
individual contributors in the first
instance and
in the latter instance you're a leader
of leaders
and your primary job is almost around
communication clarity consistency and
designing
scalable ways of interacting with all of
these people
and scalable processes it sounds more
boring than what it is but
the point is that it's so different and
and i think you need to be clear
about that because we just think about
the role and the title and think well
sure
it ought to be the same but i feel like
when people are disgruntled about the
companies changing it's because they
haven't realized that their job
changed as well and if it didn't
that role and that person would hold
back the entire company which is
obviously unacceptable
and so i talked to to the employees at
that time because there are some people
who love the startup phase
but they don't like when you're in the
mature phase
and you have to focus on efficiency
which is the kind of key metric when you
are more of a mature company and the
reality is even though i'm kind of
it and make it sound like it's one or
the other the reality is
in a larger company if done right every
single thing in the company
varies between these stages where it's
like startup where it's scale up and
where it's mature
and you go back and forth between those
different stages
in every company and every team
and it's going to be highly sort of
contextually relevant the type of
leadership
you need to have for that situation is
very very different and there are very
very few
leaders that can do all three and no
leader
that i'm aware of they can do all three
of them
incredibly well you can pass on a few of
them
but not be amazing on all three of them
so a few things that i want to
underscore for folks i feel like i'm the
the kindle highlighter of
these conversations as we go but that's
okay i
try to be useful the the first is for
people who don't recognize
reed hoffman he is the co-founder of
linkedin
and was the firefighter-in-chief or
nicknamed such
by peter thiel when at paypal and has
done many many other things
and the tour of duty concept people can
read more about also
in harvard business review if they just
search reid hoffman and
tour of duty you mentioned
a few minutes ago how very often
your role as ceo is not the decider in
chief
in every meeting right and if if you've
done things well
that there will be many decisions made
perhaps in consultation with you but
you can't scale to 5000 employees with
everything running through
daniel what do you view as your
most important jobs for some ceos
it's recruiting top talent
for others it's long term long long-term
product division in your mind
what are the absolute critical functions
if you could only choose a few that you
need to fulfill that you focus on
i actually you know one of the sort of
biggest realization for me the last few
years is that
i'm not sure the obvious thing would be
to say you can't scale and do
5000 persons jobs and that's obviously
true
but i do think that there are bottom-up
companies and top-down companies and
both can be incredibly successful
you don't have to look further than
looking at someone like elon musk
to know that he is intimately involved
in a million different details
in the company and how he managed to do
that
and how he managed to scale it's it's
beyond me i'm very impressed by it
but i know also know i couldn't do that
and it's not my philosophy
and so i think i just wanted to start by
saying i think
the the leadership style that you
ultimately have
has to be authentic to who you are and i
think a lot of us
take so much inspiration from
leaders including myself by the way
where we often
try to maybe copy someone's specific
thing that they're doing without
understanding all the underlying
mechanics
perfectly well and so i don't want to
sort of say this is what you need to do
as a leader because
i think that there are many different
leadership styles that can be
incredibly successful but i can talk
about
what is important to me as a leader in
spotify and the culture that we have
and there i am not a person that knows
everything about everything i am a much
more of a generalist
but i try to pride myself instead these
days about
trying to be a decent communicator about
an and almost like an editor of our
vision
because i feel like you have to provide
constraints
to the organization otherwise you have
these thousand flowers bloom and let's
throw things against the wall and see
what sticks
and the editor position in that end is
always back to purpose like
why are we doing things why does it
matter how does this ladder up to the
mission
and and being the constant sort of
guardrail against that and then
the second part i find is when you're
dealing with a
larger company the important part is
we all get complacent you know this is
true
um you know i i just walked walked
through i've
been having a cold no covet but like a
cold and
i i was just starting to work out again
a few days ago
and i noticed with myself that i became
complacent
like i didn't really go 100 in to this
and i was trying to
self-justify why i wasn't and
all of those things and i realized no no
no daniel you're thinking the easy way
out
and instead it ended up being that i
kind of stuck out
30 minutes longer and had probably one
of the most amazing
training sets i've had in probably six
months
and the point being is like that's the
role these days that i often have to
place i have to one
be the one who sets the bar for the
organization try to adapt
the bar for the talent that we bring in
the bar
for the ideas because complacency
is so easy to get to
and i don't know exactly why it is but i
just feel like we're all built that way
that we want to take the easy way out
and so part of this is to do the right
thing even if it's not the easy way out
and
consistently just kind of pushing the
organization to do that
and raise the bar so i play that part
too
in many parts of the organization while
almost being the
personal coach i would say which is
third role that i'm playing
because i kind of look at my role is to
enable other people to do the best work
of their careers
and what i've learned in that process is
that we're all
highly unique individuals and what
motivates me
may be entirely different than what
motivates you
and so to try to find out what
psychological barriers you have
what tensions in your life you may have
in order to try to unlock that is
something that i spend a good amount of
time on and we've touched upon some of
these things already which is
i kind of almost start with trying to
find out how you prioritize your time
because i find most people don't
prioritize their time particularly well
and in unlocking that you then have to
when you start prioritizing it you start
thinking about
what is important to you to prioritize
and this isn't just work by the way this
is in many cases i play that role for
people in their private lives too if
they want to have
more time for their kids or they want to
pursue a hobby or
they want to do x and y and they feel
like they're they're torn because
they're right in between of
you know work obligations and private
obligations and those types of things
and
i know no it sounds like pretty crazy to
talk about those
that level of detail but for me if i can
do that
for some of my leaders that in many
cases
have thousand plus people under them and
they feel
more inspired by that they're gonna
inspire hundreds if not thousands of
people
to do better and perhaps they'll pay it
forward too and we can start unlocking
more and more
of that in the organization that's kind
of my
view of what great leadership looks like
in a company like spotify but i am
so fascinated by other leaders
and how they make it work in their
cultures
you know and i i try to be a great
student
of other companies especially other
companies cultures and the reason why it
enables them to do things differently
than perhaps what we at spotify do
well let's grab an exhibit that we can
put under the microscope just for a
second because i know you and i
both know toby ceo of shopify not to be
confused with spotify but man
right to say those two in the same
sentence quickly is still challenging
for me even though i
have known both companies for so long
how uh
would you say you how are you and toby
different or how are the cultures
different you can approach this any way
you like but
in in what ways that come to mind are
the two of you different because at
surface level a lot of folks who
don't know either of you personally
would say well they're both deeply
analytical they have extremely strong
computer science backgrounds
and that's kind of where the comparison
might end
how would you describe how you're most
similar most different
or just uh look looking at approach
toby and and shopify is obviously very
inspirational
company too i i would actually say we're
we're more similar than
different um and the similarity is
um and and i've found that with some
companies by the way like
another one is like my canon brooks and
atlassian
um you know australian company i i don't
know
but a theory i have is that all of us
had to do a lot of first principle
thinking and what i mean by first
principle thinking
by not being in silicon valley and by
by not learning as much from osmosis
of just the google and facebook and
those types of cultures
we've kind of developed a different
culture
compared to the standard silicon valley
type
cultures and so in that regard i think
it's similar
and i think you know canada just like
europe
is more kind of similar in that in the
holistic
thinking about sort of the collective
rather than the individualism and
there's a lot of
rooted things and toby by the way is
german from the beginning too which is
more akin to
the swedish side so there's a lot of
similarities
between sort of philosophy upbringing
and those types of things
too i think in so the regards that we're
different
besides obviously the products and the
markets we
serve i do think it comes down to
just the way perhaps we think about sort
of talent
and you know the development of talent
and again i don't want to
sort of i don't know shopify's cultured
intimately enough to kind of pass any
remarks but
i can say at spotify
one of the big things is the thing we
just talked about which is
we instead of tour of duties we call it
internally missions
and every person at spotify has a
mission for about two years
and in particular on my leadership team
we don't make any qualms about the fact
that
things don't change or that you'll have
your job for eternity
you'll have your job for a mission and
then you and i will discuss
what the next mission ought to be and
perhaps it fits
with your skills and where you want to
go
or maybe it doesn't and this is a
big difference so when i look at my
leadership team and
certainly the extended one we've
actually shifted our leadership team
to a great extent and and my sense by
looking at toby has been
that they've kept it a little bit more
stable than than what we've done
and by the way there's no pro or cons
with both model both model works
and if anything i would say i'm probably
a little bit more envious of
the stable side um you know i i like
soccer and you know the coaches that i
like the most are the ones that develop
young players and stay with them
and like bring them to their full
potential but but i also realized that
if i were a coach i'd be more
about someone who brings in the the
sports team analogy where you bring in
a lot of super talents and get them to
work well together
my own sort of mental image of who i
want to be doesn't always
add up to the skills i have at the table
as a leader
as well and i suspect that there will be
lots of differences between us
just in the nuance between those two
things
so many different departure points from
from that answer
so fertile ground let's let's start with
uh
one that is backtracking just a little
bit actually before we get there
the we we brought up or i brought up
biographies
are there any particular biographies
that really stand out for you
for any reason well there's so many um
walter isaacson leonardo da vinci one
so phenomenal so good yeah uh pablo
picasso's biography
um also amazing i forget who the author
was who wrote it i think there's
maybe a few of them but i read one that
was
just super super interesting talking
about the creativity
constraints thinking you know that that
was kind of where
a lot of the boxes ticked for me i'm a
big
fan of biographies i'm a big fan of
of sort of unlocking yourself as you can
hear
um and and working with yourself in
order to kind of
then take on the larger community goals
or
larger societal goals that you may have
but it has to start by managing yourself
well and then from there on you can
manage others and you can
manage other stakeholders as well i
learn a lot from biographies for sure
are there any since you mentioned
management are there any particular
books
that have helped you in thinking about
management they don't have to be books
about management per se but
uh do do any any come to mind um
yeah i mean it all depends on where you
are
um right in the life cycles yeah yeah i
mean
like you know early on as a manager
there there's
high output management by andy grow is
fantastic
hard things about hard things by ben
harrow it's also really good for someone
who's
first time journey and going through and
kind of learning the basics and
there's there's a number of others about
goal setting and about financial
modeling
there's a ton of them but these days the
most inspiration i take from are
leadership journeys more than the
specific
tools in the toolbox that you can have
and
i find that is the single most
challenging things
because as we talked about a little bit
earlier you have to make leadership
personal i was having a fascinating
conversation with matthew
mcconaughey just the other day and we
talked about
how you know the roles he and characters
he takes on it has to be a part of
himself
because if it's not it's never going to
shine through and it's never gonna feel
authentic so has to bring out that
element of
himself in that character in order to
make it come alive
and i think for me and that is
when true leadership shines through as
well i'll just kind of maybe share
a personal anecdote kind of embarrassing
but but still first
kind of show yeah but but to share the
the
a little bit more about my personal
growth story so early on
like many others i modeled myself on
on being a product centric ceo kind of
silicon valley style
you know it should really be that and i
was looking at what are the best
practices what is mark zuckerberg what
does all these other guys do
and it felt like one of the one of the
things that they were doing was that
they were running the product review
meeting every week
and they were doing it really well and i
had a great
header product and i had a great product
team but i wanted to do the same thing
because i kind of just picked up that's
what a great ceo should do and i'm also
a
i'm just as good as you know the ceo of
silicon valley etc
and i remember vividly one day where
after one of these meetings
i i get pushed aside by my header
product and then he basically said look
i'll just be very honest no one enjoys
the meetings
that you're having and i was like well
why not
it's like well because you're not
actually adding anything to the meeting
and that was a very rough conversation
and
my honestly my initial instinct was very
defensive i was like well these guys
they don't understand
anything and like i probably should hire
a new head of product and i should do x
and y
but i decided against doing that and i
decided to sleep on it
and i decided to test for a while i'll
say okay well i'll see how well they do
if i don't
show up and it turns out that they did
incredibly well
without me and what i learned in that
process was i needed to
figure out a way then to add value
and i realized that rather than deciding
if the button needed to be green or blue
or even if there needed to be a button
at all that's not where i added value
where i added value in that meeting
was by sharing context that they may not
be
aware of rather than sort of pushing
towards
a decision of a particular kind or even
it wasn't about my preferences at all
but it was about sharing context
so that they can make better decisions
as a team
and it's now happened many times at
spotify where
i've had similar situations where i'm
sort of sorry to interrupt daniel what
could you
give an example of context that might be
helpful
in such a such a situation additional
context yeah
yeah so let's say you're in a product
review meeting
and you talk about what are the biggest
problems we're actually trying to solve
for the customer in this end and
oftentimes it could be
we actually find that half of the people
in the first session don't find a song
that they really love
and so the context then that i could
share in that that's the data then
the context i could share would be
either if i've had any insights
from talking to other silicon valley
ceos or other people
around what great ways to solve the
problem could be
a context in itself could be why that's
a worthwhile problem to solve in the
first place
because if we do lose half of them the
first day that means
it's kind of a funnel and it's a leaky
funnel so that's going to be
a mean problem because even if we're
only bringing in 5 000 users a day and
two and a half thousand of them stay
that may not feel like much but if we
were bringing in a hundred thousand a
day we're gonna lose 50 000 people a day
so this is a leaky
boat and we need to try to fix it and
and that context
can be incredibly valuable to share
and i was approaching this more from a
control mindset
i thought i needed to control the
prioritization of the product
and i realized instead i needed to share
more context
to enable them to make better
prioritizations themselves
and that has been something as part of
you know my journey now at spotify and
as a
development of myself i found myself now
in many
situations very similar where i thought
i was pretty good at something
and i realized that i run into someone
who knows a lot more about the topic
and is a lot more skilled than i am at
solving that problem
and so i've kind of then had to find out
a new way to add value
in that situation that's been a huge
personal growth journey for myself both
to be able to keep
up with the company but then then also
realizing
like and not being insecure about in
those moments of time when i kind of
effectively put myself out of work to
find a new job
and try to find new ways to add value to
the company
returning to the two-year missions i
would love to know maybe you can't
disclose it if you can that'd be great
do you have
a two-year mission yourself and
or what might a two-year mission look
like
is it your mission is to
do x by y using
z is is there a format to it and is it
spelled out really clearly
it's more an aspirational feeling
oftentimes sometimes it's very
tangible or oftentimes i should say it's
more an aspirational feeling what do i
want to feel once i've
accomplished or feel like i'm at this
level
but i can talk about my last one because
it's probably the most tangible
and easy one and that was just learn how
to become
a good public company ceo i said good
but not great because great will likely
take time but we went public about
two years ago and i i knew i needed to
be good
and so what are ways what does a good
public company ceo look like what are
skills that i currently don't have today
that i likely have to develop
what are the rituals um
habits you know processes to get me
there
and then work myself backwards and that
was a process
that ended for me in 2019 so i kind of
set the bar
where i would start call it a year and a
half
before going public and and then i was
hoping
i didn't anticipate to be day one
because i needed some real
loop feedback uh from the real market
but i i kind of
finalized it by at least not obviously
seeing
that i wasn't a decent one and so now
i've kind of moved on to my
sort of next mission um instead become a
three michelin star chef
yeah that would be fun my wife would
certainly love that
i'm a horrible chef another time
you can make some make some pasta
together the
aspiration to become a good public
company ceo let's
use that just as as a bit of
fodder to explore how you then
convert that into actions right because
i would imagine you
you approached it in a pretty systematic
fashion i'm looking at a description of
your
goal setting and i'll just quote here
from fast company i also write out what
my daily weekly monthly goals are and
every evening i
check how i'm doing and then i allocate
my time
then in parenthetical to match the goals
when you have something like become a
good public company ceo but you could
kind of fill in the blank with just
about anything
how do you keep yourself on track do you
break it down into
micro tasks or practices
just so you don't get lost as you
mentioned
with with lack of prioritizing how did
you approach that
yeah um i've actually started changing a
bit about it because i realized the
process was taking the overhand from the
results and i wasn't enjoying it
as much so i've made the process
somewhat simpler since that
fast company article so i think more
about
time and habits than
necessarily looking at it daily or
weekly i still kind of review my goals
for the days but i no longer have a goal
for the week
i then kind of look more at it from a
sort of quarterly basis and then
semi-annually
nowadays so it's a little bit of a tweak
just to not make it
too much overhead but the way i
approached that problem was just kind of
being clear about
what do i think oftentimes i kind of
think about it like
my mental image is that of
a city when i approach a problem and
a city from 40 000 feet above
on an airplane looking down and when you
do that you don't see the contours you
just see a city
you have no idea what aspects of the
city like what's the topography
you don't understand where it stands
where it's not dense it just looks like
a blob
and so the important part for me is i
don't know what i don't know
so i always start by allocating enough
time
so if something is important i start
allocating time towards it
and then i quickly try to spend enough
time where i can get to what i call
level two
which is when i'm more like 20 000 feet
perspective where
i can start seeing the contours of the
city i can kind of work out that
here's the rough branches of the tree so
to speak
i can't see the leaves i can't see the
details i can see all
all of those things but i kind of have
an idea of blocks
to start diving into and so if you look
at something like
that you know you have to understand
more about one block is understanding
the constituents
in what way is a public market ceo
different than
than a vc it turns out that they're
quite different
so understanding the motives the
motivations
understanding what different types of
them exist which one of them
do i want to attract which one of them
should i possibly even talk about not
attracting
speaking about the jeff bezos quotes you
are the shareholder you deserve
um that kind of rings very true to me in
the sense that should we
as a company be part of the expectation
setting as a public company it's very
fashionable
for instance in silicon valley to not
give guidance
going forward because you don't care
about the quality results
i find it ironic because what it
essentially says is that you don't want
to be part of the participation
of the expectations that the market does
on your company
but they'll still have expectations so
the question is just if you want to
participate in that expectation setting
or not
it's not like you you really have a
choice that there won't be an
expectation
and so after seeing those nuances i
realized that it was actually
very important to me to be part of that
expectation setting because if
i'm going to be beholden to something
i'd rather
be beholden to something which i was a
part of informing them about rather than
something that they just made up their
mind all by themselves
and when you realize that you realize
that communication
becomes super important as one of the
skills
and how do you for someone who has a lot
of optionality of their time
communicate succinctly what the company
is they're not going to spend every
weekend moments
of the company or their lives thinking
about your company they
might many times have other companies
that they follow as well
so putting yourself in that mindset
starting to see
the nuances starting to see the blocks
then start to
think about what habits can lead up to
the skills that you desire and even the
increasing the resolution so to speak of
the
the image i just said about the city so
that you see all the streets see all
those things
um is super important for me as i think
about
a mission of mine and and even honestly
just
learning about a subject that i'm
interested in i kind of
use the same process over and over which
is that kind of
the city uh mental model where elon musk
talks about it as the tree the branches
the leaves
which was also kind of an inspirational
thing
that i took away from i can't remember
but it was one of his
interviews um probably a few years ago
so i want to give an example of
communication and a quote that has
been shared quite widely but i think
that it would be nice to have you just
explain
in brief the gist of it what it what it
means and the quote is
quote we believe that speed of iteration
beats quality of iteration
which is why we're not big on
bureaucracy and i want to focus on the
first part of that
speed of iteration beats quality of
iteration could you explain what that
means please
uh yeah um you know again um
the the i i when i evaluate
success um among a future leader
at spotify or even someone who just
joined the company
i look at the rate of their learning
growth i find that to be the best
indicator for whether they will be
long-term successful
in their job at spotify or not
and the gist of it is i think
macro wise first and foremost that the
world is changing just constantly
and you have to adapt to that change so
i value
agility and learning way more than i
value the fact that you're really good
at your job and just doing
really good at doing a few things the
other aspect of that
that i think is important is the
notion not only about the sort of the
world changing
or any of that sort but but also perhaps
maybe
more my own personality more than
anything else i love learning
first and foremost and the second thing
is i am not steve jobs
or elon musk i don't just intuitively
know what the world will look like and i
don't think most people do
i think most people learn as they go
and so if you create an environment
where you can fail
that is transparent and where you're
allowed to iterate
and learn on the job you will create
a learning organism that keeps getting
better and better and better
at hopefully a higher and higher pace
than ever before
and that for me as a culture feels a lot
more resilient
than one that relies on someone
having a god-like ability to see the
future before
anyone else sees it i've never been that
type of entrepreneur i
i wouldn't know where to begin in
inventing the next iphone
but i do know how to make something a
bit better
than it was yesterday and i do think
that i know some things about the world
but i also know in that process i'll
learn a new thing
a lot of new things if i keep developing
and iterating as i go along
let's hop to a completely different
species of learning organism
and that is brilliant minds what is
brilliant minds and how did it start
oh yeah um so brilliant minds is a
conference that i started together with
ash ponori
who is the manager of avicii um a few
years back
and the genesis of the idea in all
honesty
started by ash and i traveling around
the world
many times often having to explain
sweden to people
who've never been there there are
aspects again
about the culture i'd we talked about it
in the beginning about
some of the very very distinct swedish
stuff and then
in some part um the quote you know the
futures here just
unevenly distributed also rings very
true
about sweden we had broadband in 1998
part of the reason
why i believe spotify came to be was
i saw the need for it probably
earlier than others because i i had
you know 100 megabit broadband in 1998.
yeah that's why so there was nothing
yeah and so because there was nothing
for me to do
i could only use file sharing services
and i realized that it was wrong
but it was a lot better than the
alternative of going down to the video
store
which only had about half of the things
that i actually wanted to see
so that kind of inspired me and then
later on
after starting a few companies then
started spotify and so
i wanted to bring sweden to the rest of
the world and frankly i wanted to bring
the rest of the world
to sweden too and and create kind of a
two-way exchange
street and so we started this conference
which is kind of an unconference
conference where
very light almost ted style talks 10 15
minutes long lots and lots of music
lots and lots of time to interact with
other people and
the focus is around creativity and
you know we bring people from music from
arts we bring people
from business and technology together
and
talk about what some of the larger
problems in society exist today
and frankly try to inspire them to
see if they can make a difference in
some shape or form
it's pretty small it's just a few
hundred guests and
um yeah i mean it's it's been a fun fun
journey to see the relationships that's
been formed
and and i certainly for swedes it's been
you know uh so valuable to be able to
learn
from some of the most creative and
amazing individuals
in the world so i think paying dividends
in spades when it comes to sweden
you've dedicated as i understand it i
mean this would be an understatement but
significant resources to
funding uh and supporting i suppose
predominantly moonshots
in is it is it across the is it across
europe is it specific to sweden
how are you thinking about cultivating
that that ecosystem
using your own resources yeah um
so it's a billion euros um and it's
across europe that's why i said an
understatement
yeah yeah that's a lot of a lot of
a lot of commas yeah but but
but truthfully the number in itself
isn't the most important thing
and people actually ask me where i got
the number from and the number was the
most uncomfortable thing i could imagine
and sometimes i work that way i just put
out a very
sort of big audacious quantifiable thing
and i worked myself towards okay what
does it have to look like and
what could we do with that as a
constraint
and this very much ended up being that
way and
the genesis of the thinking was actually
quite multi-sided
but when you look at europe as a as an
ecosystem
for startups and technology
it is very much behind the most mature
ecosystems in america
and the most obvious way to look at that
is to say
if you look at europe uh it has about
400 and
uh it's more than 400 million depending
on how you look at it it's five to seven
hundred million people
with about the same gdp if not more than
usa and yet when you look at the most
valuable companies
you can't find a single company with the
exception of sap
in the technology space that is worth
more than 100 billion that comes from
europe
and at the same time you can find a
number of them in
in the us and not only that nowadays you
can even find a few trillion dollar
companies
as well and for me that's just
unthinkable
like why would that be you have every
single
core component necessary the amount of
engineers in europe
rivals the ones from the us the amount
of
scientists we have in europe easily
rivals the one
in the us so all those record
ingredients
are there but it's still not happening
the goal
really essentially is how can we
leapfrog the current development which
by the way is heading in the right way
so it's slowly getting better
and there are more and more
entrepreneurs that are thinking bigger
there are more and more people that
pursue entrepreneurship which is
fantastic to see
and there's more and more capital that
supports and more and more experience in
the ecosystem so all trends are in the
right direction
but we're still maybe 20 years behind
and so the question
then ends up being is there a way we can
leapfrog
the evolution of the ecosystem and is
there a way
where we at the same time can take on
some of society's largest
issues and try to make a real dent in
those types
of of issues and that's essentially
the genesis of the moonshots and
why i've decided to dedicate you know a
significant portion of
my wealth to try to see if i can help
make that happen for europe and for
hopefully the world
too and yeah and it just felt like
a scary big uh kind of audacious thing
to try to pursue
and and frankly a lot better than than
just sitting on the money and not doing
anything
collecting marbles yeah i agree with
that
and it seems like some of the targets
that certainly have implications for
addressing very significant problems and
meeting challenges and
looking forward into the next 10 20
years and beyond
would include machine learning
biotechnology material sciences
energy and that is
it's very exciting to put
the type of resources that you're
applying into those fields
in europe to me for a number of reasons
and
one we won't have time to get into today
is
to see how that changes vis-a-vis
incentives right we were talking about
charlie munger earlier
the attraction retention of talent
and as i've seen with say shopify in
ottawa canada which is the last place
people would expect
maybe not the last place but it's not on
the top
three in mind share for say startup
communities but
because they are not subject i suppose
somewhat similar to duolingo and
pittsburgh also
to facebook and google and apple trying
to poach their engineers every second
right around the corner they they have
some real
competitive advantages so it'll be very
exciting to see
what type of not just
standing on equal ground can be created
in europe but also advantages
for people who happen to be located or
choose to locate themselves
in europe so i commend commend what
you're doing
well thank you yeah i mean it's it's
it's it's early days
but uh i feel like it's it's one of
those things where
it's either going to be very successful
or
uh we will talk about all the lessons
from the failure
uh in a few years hopefully when we do
this again
that's kind of how i like living my life
by the way i don't like
the the safe lane i prefer the
uncomfortable lane
where it either becomes big
or you kind of go home and and
yeah it's it's it's the i guess the kind
of very typical
entrepreneurial spirit but i've tried to
remain
you know naive enough to want to pursue
those types of
of um opportunities well i think
naive might be one way to put it i think
agile and observant would be two other
ways to put it because
we're not going to have time to really
dig into the value
of failure but there's a fetishizing of
failure in silicon valley in some cases
but
the reason that i think you are so
capable in part of harnessing failure
as the tinder for larger flames of
of success is because of that
commitment to learning organisms and
constraints
and review right that type of assessment
the mentality of two-year missions i
think that it's this incredible sort of
structure and system of habits
that you've built around it that allows
you to again
impart so convert so effectively so we
won't have time to talk about the ufc
i'm sad about that
we won't have time to talk about
alexander the maul or gustafsson i i
really
at some point want to talk to you about
your interest i love you
yeah so some other time some other time
guitar there are all these subjects that
we that we won't have time in this round
one
so last question or maybe second to last
and
this this question is is sometimes a
tough one but we'll throw it out there
anyway
and that is if you had a billboard
metaphorically speaking to get a message
a quote a question an image anything out
to billions of people
non-commercial what might you put on
that billboard
oh wow i i don't know how i would find a
way to
write this a lot more marketable than
the way i'm gonna put it now so that it
would resonate with more people
but i think the single biggest thing
that's striking to me right now with all
the polarization on
all the different issues that we're
facing is in other words be kind
uh everyone is on their own journey and
i've encountered so many fates
and life situations certainly over the
last nine months ago where i've learned
so much
i learned about issues i didn't even
know exist that
i learned about situations and hardships
but also successes and uh happiness as
well so
all of those different things but uh
what what it kind of reminded me on is
that we're all on our own journey we're
definitely not perfect
you know this part why i wanted to talk
a little bit about my own sort of
journey and growth because you know i'm
um
i i don't even know whether i would
consider myself particularly good
at anything um so
you know and then that's actually like a
mental thing that i constantly struggle
with because i
constantly face people who i i always
find are smarter
than me deeper than me on various
subjects and
like all of that stuff i think we're all
on journeys
and we all have our own insecurities we
have all our own
stuff that's happening in our lives and
just to be mindful about that
just be mindful about that we're all
going through things
has created a lot of empathy for me and
created a lot of understanding for me as
i meet co-workers
as i meet people out in society as well
and um yeah i mean it's especially
important as we sit now in our own homes
and digitally type away on twitter and
other things
not thinking too much about whose
feelings we may hurt or not because we
can't read each other's emotions
and so yeah be kind everyone's on their
journey would be that
that's i think the perfect way to wrap
up daniel
firesoul this has been a lot of fun i
really appreciate
you carving out the time across time
zones
to have a wide-ranging
romp of a conversation that was it was
very non-linear so
i uh i appreciate you playing ball thank
you so much
of course well thank you so much for
having me this was a blast so i hope to
do it again sometime yeah that would be
great i've got i've already had
i put r2 which is a within highlighter
around all these subjects that we didn't
get to just in case we do a round two so
we'll have plenty
for next time if we do and how do you
say let's say
now in in swedish is there something
like tuzantak
how would you say uh how would you say
yes i still need to work on my vowels
but one word at a time
and perfect really appreciate you being
so
open to so many questions and
to everyone listening we will have links
to
everything discussed ranging from
brilliant minds to the books and
everything in between
in the show notes at tim dot blog
forward slash podcast and
until next time be kind and realize
everyone is on
their own journey
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the
the world of the esoteric as i do it
could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just a little tiny
bite of goodness before you head off for
the weekend so if you want to receive
that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
headspace life could be stressful even
under
normal circumstances 2020 has challenged
even the most resilient people i know
it's highlighted
just how much we all need stress relief
that goes beyond quick
fixes or really the hope for just a one
and done band-aid
quick is fine but we need stuff that is
durable and that's where headspace
comes in headspace is your daily dose of
mindfulness in the form of guided
meditations
in an easy to use app now you might ask
yourself
very reasonably there are 2 000 plus
apps for meditation
why would i use headspace headspace is
one of the only meditation apps
advancing the field of mindfulness and
meditation through clinically validated
research
and space is backed by 25 published
studies on its benefits
600 000 5 star reviews and more than 60
million
downloads so people keep telling you to
try meditation and you're like when
would i do that
when would i possibly have time you
should check out headspace if you have
10 minutes
headspace can change your life headspace
offers
a really light lift and a lot
of features to keep you going which is
part of the reason that i've used
headspace for years now so whatever the
situation
headspace can really help you feel
better overwhelmed headspace has a
three-minute sos meditation view need
some help falling asleep
headspace has wind down sessions their
members swear by and for parents
headspace even has morning meditations
you can do with your kids
headspace's approach to mindfulness can
reduce stress improve sleep
use focus and increase your overall
sense
of well-being and it really starts with
very very
simple practices and if you look at
my case for instance i just went through
one of the
basics today with the
co-founder andy i think it's put a [ __ ]
could be putty comb i'm not sure but
former monk
turned into co-founder of headspace has
the most soothing hypnotic voice
imaginable and i did a three minute
meditation
something like that it's easy it's
fundamental
and it always puts me in a better space
so i'm going through the basics even
though i've meditated for years i'm
going through the basics once again
and i would suggest to anyone that they
consider starting there
headspace makes it easy for you to build
a life-changing meditation practice with
mindfulness that works for you
on your schedule anytime anywhere we all
want to feel happier
we all want more peace and headspace is
meditation
made simple go to headspace.com tim
that's headspace.com tim for a free one
month trial
with access to headspace's full library
of meditations for every
conceivable possible situation you
can break glass in case of emergency in
almost any situation and find something
on headspace
this is the best deal offered right now
for headspace
so check it out go to headspace.com
tim today this episode is brought to you
by literary
l-i-t-e-r-a-t-i i absolutely love
what literary is doing and i've been
waiting for someone to really pull it
off
so finally right here in my hometown of
austin but available
nationwide literary let me back up for a
second though if there's one thing i
think we're all craving
after this completely insane captain
insano year
it's an uplifting holiday season we want
the celebrations the community and
bonding conversations
that will give us some hope and
inspiration going into 2021
that's where literati can really help
litterati is a subscription book club
that sends a beautiful book to your door
each month
hand-picked by world-renowned authors
and leaders literati has book clubs
curated by
fascinating luminaries of all different
types including
the unbreakable malala yousafzai
basketball icon stephen curry
entrepreneurial legend richard branson
and famed author and new york staff
writer
susan orlin there are many many
different books
to choose from and the focusing function
here
the filtering function is what's
important
because with more than a million new
books released every year finding the
right needle in the haystack the best
signal amidst the noise
can be really hard can be super daunting
and literary
takes care of it for you every month you
get one paperback or hardcover book
that's specific to your luminaries club
like malala's club fearless or stephen
curry's club underrated
these are life-changing books personally
picked by awe-inspiring people
there's a personal forward from your
luminary in each month's book
and you're also able to use the literati
app to discuss what you read with people
who are reading the same book
as well as the luminaries slash curators
themselves so they do
engage the literary app gives you
exclusive access to discussions led by
malala stephen curry richard branson
susan orlane and others
you won't get insight or access like
this anywhere else and the way they put
it together is really beautiful
i have seen a couple of different
packages that have been sent to me
and they're just gorgeous they're really
well done and it
makes the act of reading easy and it
makes it extremely
pleasant so get the books that the
world's most fascinating minds are
reading
every month and you can cancel any time
you can give subscriptions
which are available for three six or 12
months of books it's a great way to keep
the holiday magic going through 2021
whether you're gifting a friend a family
member or yourself
and it's easy go to literati dot com
slash tim
to find your perfect book club and sign
up today that's l-i-t-e-r-a-t-i
dot com slash tim no one else has book
clubs quite like these go to
literary.com
tim to get one book every month curated
by today's leading authors and
visionaries
so make your holidays unforgettable this
year and make someone else's holidays
aren't for you
might as well go to literary.com tim one
more time this literati.com
you